[Music]
you love the first base jam
because you were like eight now
it's time for the next generation to get
their own looney tunes nba crossover
but while the first one was merely
inspired by a commercial the all-new
sequel
just is a commercial show them who you
really are
notorious p-i-g
what in the matrix hell it goes on like
this for like two
hours space jam 2
a new legacy since 96
warner brothers has been searching for
an athlete big enough to fill michael
jordan's enormous genes
and after waiting for decades they shrug
and settle for lebron james
the michael jordan of leaving for a
better team ran out of teams to play for
he's a basketball icon who refuses to
shut up and dribble
in fact he'll say everything from what
what
what to what the what the what the
what the to
[Music]
in a performance that uses the latest in
practical and digital effects
to fix his airline and then i don't lean
up until i see
while he starts mj would never
watch is a guy who's known for being
electrifying on the court and a corny
goofball off it
is cast as a joyless grump who plays
boring basketball
everything in between these four lines
has worked and when his son dom
gets kidnapped by his nemesis a cleverly
named villain will win the kid over
by showing him all the love and
encouragement he's missing at home
forcing the dad to round up a bunch of
cartoonish misfits from a land where
they don't age
and convince them to help him fight back
against the bad guy until he learns to
let loose have some fun
and believe he can fly bang a ring bang
a ring hey can we just watch hook
instead
don cheadle co-stars as a slightly
different kind of war machine
algae rhythm he's got a plan to steal
all lebron's social media followers
and like have fun with that dude he'll
do it by kidnapping some of basketball's
most available talent of the time of
filming
all to be lebron at his son's blade and
nba jam rip-off
plus he wants to kill the looney tunes i
think it gets kind of murky
honestly once the horny nuns and the
iron giant showed up i just tuned out
and scanned the background for easter
eggs
oh hey look at that jabber jaw need
how do you do fellow kids it's the
looney tunes they may have peaked during
the korean war
but that won't stop them from doing all
the latest memes of 2003.
there's bugs bunny who turns in a
performance that can only be described
as
off-brand bugs bunny i'm a tune doc and
the return
of lola bunny a rabbit i'd like to
flatter because of her strong work ethic
yeah that's it but who cares about the
looney tunes
this movie sure doesn't what they really
want to showcase is warner's exciting
catalog of properties
that they've run into the ground from
the hit show that got ruined by its last
two seasons
the brandon of house stuff
to the hit films that got ruined by
their last two sequels
wine i love french wine to the hit
franchise that's being ruined by jk
rowling's last two brain cells
honestly this one we should have focused
on wiley coyote if anyone he put up 524
points in the final game mvp
mvp so enjoy the film equivalent of a
genetic mistake
begging to be put out of its misery with
a villain who embodies a creatively
bankrupt movie studio
staffed by incompetent executives a new
idea from the algorithm
i'm listening some of the greatest 2d
animated characters of all time
transformed into cgi freaks against
their will
not do that and a hero who laments how
corporations force ips to cross over for
cash
they all left then does exactly that
but who cares it's just a dumb kids
movie as long as they have that come on
and slam song in there we'll call it
even
come on slam or no one will feel welcome
at your jam
starring cleveland steamer
say doc again i dare you catch some
fancy footwork doc stop talk
stop stop stop stop duck duck duck
dog doctor da da da what's
that's big jungus personal foul nice try
movie but i'm also horny for solid
basketball fundamentals
m la dub james sorry don't get crushed
gotcha
come on bro this character wasn't even
in the script
don just showed up on molly and started
talking like this
child murderers and a woman who tortures
and
imprisons her disabled sister good thing
that cut pepe le pew out of this movie
whew
that could have been problematic it's
not tv
it's an ad for hbo
did a video game write this movie it's
like basketball but
better but everybody on the team plays
lebron dom built a video game oh
nice you're on video game let's get a
look at that game of yours hey if i'm
gonna be in this game i need a super
power or something i need one of those
special modes your game is amazing son
style points power-ups see kids playing
video games do pay off
you could argue if lebron is better than
jordan all day but you know who might be
better than
both air bud we crunch the numbers on
the best boy's career stats across all
five films to determine if he's the
greatest athlete of all time
click the box on the right to find out
duck season
rabbit even rabbit season duck even